my name is Susanna Kaelin I'm 21 years
old and Here I am with my dream job at
the New York Post gross why are you
smiling this early in the morning so
natural and specimen you look ridiculous
you're gonna do that creepy Center will
have a Thursday night I know I will just
I can always count on you I had my whole
life in front of me and I had absolutely
no idea what was waiting for me we've
tested Susanna for every infectious
disease all of the results are negative
we're gonna get to the bottom in this
together her EEG is completely normal
her MRI is normal her neurological exam
is normal it's all normal
her condition continues to regress manic
behavior annoy us each of them is giving
us a different diagnosis one is a
bipolar next menacing schizophrenic who
then they're saying psychotic we should
look at hospitals that are better
equipped to deal
[Music]
to all of us you will find the answer
her life is in your hands tell me what
is wrong with my daughter you must be
the famous Susana that's I know she's
still in there
she's just trapped I promise you I'm
going to do everything you can to fight
you know time is of the essence
[Music]
you